hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the terms that's most closely
associated with sigmund freud
and with psychoanalysis as a movement
and a method
is the unconscious
and freud in lecture 31
the dissection of the psychical
personality
wants to clarify for us
what the unconscious or what unconscious
really means and as it turns out he says
it's an equivocal term
it covers a range of different
to some degree interrelated meanings
that we we have to distinguish and
clarify if we want to really understand
what he's trying to say he begins by
talking
about resistance and he says
that the whole theory of psychoanalysis
is as you know built on built up on the
perception of the resistance
offered to us by the patient when we
attempt to make his
unconscious conscious to him and that's
really
central to psychoanalysis right the idea
is that you have
some things going on that you don't
really know about
and they can be located in something
that we can almost think like a bucket
that you know is the unconscious we're
gonna
pull things out of the bucket not not
the best analogy of course but
you know the patient resists and doesn't
want to hear certain things or they
misrecognize
and so this is a key insight on the part
of freud he says that the objective sign
of this resistance is that his
associations fail or depart widely from
the topic that's being
dealt with they start ranging into other
things he may also recognize the
resistance subjectively
by the fact that he has distressing
feelings when he approaches
the topic but this last sign may also be
absent and he says we say to the patient
we infer from his behavior
he's now in a state of resistance and he
replies i don't know anything about that
and is only aware that the associations
have become more difficult
and in this case freud says we can talk
about even the resistances
being unconscious that the patient is
not aware of them
even though as an observer the
psychoanalyst
might be aware of them so he goes on he
says
the resistance was unconscious too just
as unconscious as the repressed
the lifting of which we were working and
so we should long ago have asked the
question
from what part of his mind does an
unconscious
resistance like this arise and here's
where freud
is going to say listen you popularizers
of psychoanalysis you people who have
like studied it a bit
and now we're going to use it as the
hermeneutic to understand everything
don't make this mistake and what is
the mistake we ask well what part of the
mind is this resistance coming from
the unconscious and freud says that's
not
actually solving anything to just
attribute it to this
you know thing that we all now know
about because of
psychoanalysis he says the beginner
will begin with with saying that the
resistance of the unconscious and freud
says an ambiguous and
unserviceable answer if it means the
resistance arises from the repressed
we must rejoin certainly not we have to
attribute to the repressed
an upward drive so it's not the
repressed thing that's resisting
it wants to get out and talk and be
conscious right
he says the resistance can only be a
manifestation of the ego
which originally put the repression into
force and now wishes to maintain it
now if that's the case
that means that part of the ego
is now unconscious so
that's a bit of a problem for the people
who want to say oh
so the ego is what's conscious it's your
thinking
aware self and then there's this whole
unconscious stuff
underneath it no a good portion of the
ego at any given time is
itself unconscious so he says since
we've come to assume a special agency in
the ego the superego which represents
demands
of a restricting and rejecting character
we can say that repression
is the work of this superego and it's
carried out either by itself or by the
ego
in obedience to its orders if we're met
by the case of resistance and analysis
not being conscious to the patient this
means
either that in quite important
situations the super
ego and the ego can operate
unconsciously
or that portions of them the ego and the
superego themselves are unconscious
so this is a very different portrayal by
freud
of these you know superego ego key ideas
of psychoanalysis very different than
what his popularizers
have sometimes portrayed them as and he
goes on and he says
you know i in the face of the doubt
whether the ego and super ego are
themselves unconscious
or merely produce unconscious effects we
have decided in favor of the former
personality
this doesn't mean that the entirety of
the ego is unconscious
if that was the case we wouldn't be
having any conversation at all
about the ego because we obviously are
using in freudian senses our egos to
have this
this very investigation going on
but as he says large
parts of the ego and the superego at any
given time
are unconscious now the question then is
all right unconscious in what way what
do we actually mean
when we're talking about something being
unconscious or
the unconscious and here is where he
starts clarifying terminology and he
says
there's no need to discuss what's to be
called conscious it's removed from all
doubt we know what it means right it's
sort of a
basic experience that we have
so the oldest and best meaning of the
word unconscious he says
is the descriptive one what do we mean
by that we're describing
psychical processes we say that a
psychical process is unconscious
whose existence we are obliged to assume
for some such reason as we infer it from
its effects
but of which we know know nothing so i
mean this is really a metaphysical
conception
isn't it where we're saying um it's sort
of like a
there's a cause and we infer the cause
from its effects we don't actually know
the cause directly
but we observe the effects and we say
there must be something
lying behind these so he says in the
that case
we have the same relation to it as we
have to a psychical process in another
person
is a very interesting thing to say right
except that it is in fact one of our own
so you know we see another person
getting
angry about something and you know
knocking things around we must say well
somebody must have
ticked them off or they had some setback
that they didn't like now we find
ourselves doing the same thing and we're
like
what the hell am i doing here well i i
must be
carrying on some reasoning processes
and some processes of moving from you
know
assumptions and and perceptions to these
actions and i i can infer that in myself
and i can do this with other things as
well i
find myself constantly getting upset
in the presence of one person but not in
another well there must be something to
it right
i just don't know what it is that's
unconscious to me so he goes on and he
says that
um if we want to be more correct
we can modify our assertion by saying
that we call a process unconscious
if we're obliged to assume that it is
being activated
at the moment although at the moment we
know nothing about it and he says this
is a really important qualification
why because it makes us reflect that the
majority of conscious
processes are conscious for only a short
time
most of the time we're not actually
paying attention
that closely to what's going on not just
around us but
within us our own processes of thinking
and association and feeling and
responses
we're paying attention to some of it but
we're usually not paying attention to
most of it
and we can direct our attention we can
look at well
i'm going to do some mindfulness now and
you know pay attention to my breathing
and wow you know my breath sounds kind
of weird okay i was unconscious of that
before but now i can be
conscious of that so he says that
this you know this makes us realize that
things can become latent but they can
easily become conscious again
we might also say they had become
unconscious if it were
at all certain that in the condition of
latency they are still something
psychical and so you know this is this
is quite
uh interesting and he says that um so
far we'd have learned nothing new nor
should we have acquired the right to
introduce into the concept of
unconscious into psychology
but then come the parapraxis
in order to explain a slip of the tongue
we find ourselves obliged to assume the
intention was to make
a particular remark was present in
the subject right so we look at this
association
stuff and a lot of that has been carried
on unconsciously
and so he says from this experience we
obtained the right to pronounce
something
as something unconscious what had been
described as latent
and so we can move from this descriptive
idea to distinguishing two kinds of
being unconscious there's the thing that
he's going to call the pre-conscious
in which we can fairly easily
make it conscious we just have to direct
our attention to it and now it comes
into the light or prominence whatever we
want to call it of consciousness
it's latent for a while right and then
there's the things that are
genuinely unconscious oftentimes
involving resistances right or
repression because they're transformed
into consciousness
only through difficulty
or not at all and this is where the you
know the psychoanalyst can actually be
quite helpful
in pointing out to a person that what
they're
not conscious of is actually
affecting their behaviors leading to
inferences
you know making them choose certain
terms even though they can't be
aware of it even though they can't
understand in the experiential sense why
it's happening they could understand in
a cognitive sense though
so he he goes on and he says that um
there has
you know in this case we have a
considerable expenditure of effort
and so he says in order to escape the
ambiguity as to whether we mean the one
or the other unconscious
we're going to um call the unconscious
which is only latent and easily becomes
conscious pre-conscious and
use the term conscious for the other now
we have three terms conscious
pre-conscious
unconscious and he says this you know
would be very simple if it remained like
that
but there's another wrinkle there as a
matter of fact we
use unconscious in a third
sense he says in which we're referring
to something like a system
he uses the adjectives topographical
and systematic to describe it he also
talks about it as being
in the the unconscious in the truly
dynamic
sense and so he talks about a conflict
between the
ego and the system unconscious which
he's going to now actually dispense with
and he says
i've used the word more and more to
denote a mental province rather than a
quality of what's mental
the discovery is actually an
inconvenient one
because portions of the ego and superego
as well are unconscious in a dynamic
sense
but we can realize he says
we perceive that we have no right to
name the mental region that's foreign to
the ego
the system unconscious since the
characteristic of being unconscious
is not restricted to it he says fine
we're not going to
use this term unconscious in the
systematic sense and we will
give what we have hitherto so described
a better name
one no longer open to misunderstanding
and he takes this from
a verbal usage of nietzsche and talks
about the
id the s in german right the the
it that's within us that drives us and
there's a lot more to be said about that
here the last thing that we need to
bring up is that
freud tells us that we have to be very
careful
not to try to identify things too
closely
the ego is not the same thing as the
conscious
the superego is not the same thing as
the pre-conscious
the id is not the same thing as
unconscious there are parts of the
ego and the superego that are
unconscious the id
is very often you know uh unconscious
although you could say parts of it are
actually pretty pre-conscious
you know the parts that are lustful or
gluttonous or whatever you want
the entirety of the id probably not
right but
you you can't easily identify these with
each other and here he's got this you
know really interesting
metaphor or analogy of the
hill country planes and chains of lakes
with the mixed
population to try to explain that and
the point that he's trying to make there
is don't
don't identify these three things
here with these other three things here
conscious pre-conscious
unconscious is not the same thing as ego
superego
and id so a lot of different meanings of
unconscious and freud is
is keen to have us understand the
differences
between them so that we can make sense
out of these three
agencies that play such an important
role that's the dissection he's trying
to carry out
in this lecture
you